alexis poulain c'est notre rubrique
l'édito mais bon soir alexis poulain
merci d'être avec nous en direct sur rt
france on l'a vu donc une nouvelle
tribune de militaires appellent à à
l'insurrection pour vous ou sursaut
salutaire alors je crois pas que ces
tribunes appel à l'insurrection
clairement il dit une chose c'est que le
pays n'est plus gouverné ou que quelque
chose ne va plus en france c'est un
appel à l'aide
une alerte clairement posée par des
militaires pour qui j'ai énormément de
respect qui sont sur les théâtres
d'opérations qui sont là pour défendre
les populations et le pays qu'ils savent
de quoi ils parlent
tout comme les policiers qui aussi sont
en train de parler au premier ministre
ce soir et qui n'en peuvent plus
finalement d'un laisser-aller puisque
c'est un peu ça qui est critiquée de ce
quinquennat et des quinquennat précédent
de dire vous connaissez les problèmes
vous les politiques et vous n'avez rien
fait
aujourd'hui si vous ne faites rien alors
oui peut-être que nous allons entrer
dans un moment insurrectionnel dangereux
où certains parlent même de guerre
civile je crois qu'il faut pas il faut
redescendre d'un cran
il faut pas s'enflammer derrière on
parle bien sûr de signature anonyme
puisque le devoir de réserve de l'armée
est essentielle si on parle de guerre
civile c'est qu'on veut aussi peut-être
la guerre civile et c'est là où c'est
dangereux je crois qu'il ya une analyse
juste qui est le laisser-faire le
laisser aller après la réponse qui
serait celle de dire qu'il faut utiliser
les armes qu'il faut utiliser la
violence qu'il faut aller plus loin dans
cette réponse là n'est pas forcément la
bonne
mais le problème il est sur la table
aujourd'hui c'est que fait emmanuel
macron que fait son gouvernement pour
répondre à ses inquiétudes pour protéger
les populations françaises pour protéger
les policiers dans l'exercice de leur
métier
ou bien les militaires qui sont des
cibles du terrorisme et l'islamic ça on
le sait donc je crois que c'est surtout
ça que disent ces tribunes
et puis on voit bien que comme on est
dans une année importante avant
l'élection présidentielle de 2000 22 et
bien elles sont utilisées et à dessein
par marine le pen notamment puisque
l'aca fait écho à des thèmes de campagne
qui lui sont chers qu elle a toujours
fait et qui est un vocabulaire aussi qui
peut être proche de celui utilisé par
les cercles dit de l'extrême droite donc
voilà pourquoi cette tribune je pense
faire
autant de vagues la ministre des armées
florence parly est obligé de se
positionner par rapport à ça en disant
qu'on doit pas dire des choses pareilles
c'est saper les valeurs de la république
mais je crois qu'on peut saper les
valeurs de la république de plein de
façons différentes et il est là toute la
question c'est finalement un débat
philosophique de ce qu'est la sécurité
ce qu'est la france
et pourquoi aujourd'hui des militaires
sont contraints de sortir des tribunes
de manière anonyme
c'est du jamais vu et ça dit plus de la
feuille du politique que de la faillite
de ces militaires qui sont finalement
dans un devoir de réserve permanent et
qui la sorte de leur groupe avec si vous
venez de le dire le thème de la sécurité
qui s'imposent de plus en plus qui
devient plus que j'aime bien un enjeu
politique
illustration avec les passes d'armes un
vrai feuilleton auquel ont assisté ce
week-end entre marine le pen et eric
dupond moretti dans les hauts de france
oui mais tout est là finalement on voit
bien que emmanuel macron a passé son
temps à se mettre en scène dans ce
quinquennat
d'ailleurs la journée du 8 mai on le
voit se mettre en scène avec l'état
major avec un drone qui survole cette
réunion entre le président et l'état
major du jamais vu c'est bien sûr pour
uniquement faire des images pour
rassurer dire qu'il est le chef des
armées et donc il a choisi dans cette
mise en scène son adversaire principal
et c'est marine le pen est depuis le
début de ce quinquennat il a tout fait
pour que en 2022 on se retrouve dans la
même situation qu'en 2017
avec ce second tour où il serait face à
marine le pen son adversaire préféré
donc il fait tout pour que ça arrive
pourquoi ils envoient monsieur dupont
moretti dans les hauts de france parce
que finalement le candidat initial de la
république met en marche ne fera aucun
score il le sait donc ils envoient un
ténor connu qui est pourtant ministre de
la justice il a autre chose à faire
uniquement pour saper les chances de
xavier bertrand de gagner largement la
région nord est pour diminuer ses
chances pour la course à la
présidentielle
donc c'est de la tactique politicienne
de bas étage dangereux puisque
finalement que fait mal macron ils
misent sur le fait que les français
votre à nouveau pour lui contre marine
le pen
or les temps ont changé et beaucoup de
gens sont excédés de la politique des
valeurs acron sa base n'a pas évolué il
reste sur une base qui à peu près la
même qu'en 2017 qui s'est érodée
d'ailleurs de son côté gauche il
essaye tant bien que mal de rattraper
sur le côté droit avec un gérald
darmanin qui en fait davantage sur la
sécurité
on voit bien qu'ils sont encore bien en
deçà de ce qui est attendu des forces de
police ou bien des populations dans les
quartiers difficiles et tout est à
l'envi avec une stratégie uniquement
d'arrivée face à marine le pen au second
tour en 2022 mais il ya un premier tour
avant le second tour
et puis il ya des idées qui sont en
train de gagner aussi celle de marine le
pen en l'occurrence qui prennent du
terrain donc ce choix de dupond moretti
c'est un choix tactique pas forcément le
plus malin mais qui en dit long sur la
tactique national de long terme dévorer
le maquereau alors justement un dernier
sondage c'est édifiant quarante deux
pour cent des français estiment que le
fn ne représente pas un danger pour la
démocratie mais ils ne sont qu'un tiers
à l'estimé capable de gouverner et qu'un
quart seulement a jugé marine le pen que
marine le pen ferait une bonne
présidente de la république comment
expliquez vous ces chiffres par ailleurs
en hausse 1 comment tout simplement
parce que les thèmes défendus par marine
le pen depuis des années sont devenus
des thèmes récurrents devenu centraux au
débat politique national que ce soit le
thème de la sécurité
le thème de l'immigration tous ces
thèmes là qu'elle a martelé année après
année que son père martelé avant elle
mais ils sont devenus au coeur de tous
les débats et puis marine le pen elle
est devenue même le centre de
l'attention de tous les politiques en
france c'est l'alpha et l'oméga de la
stratégie de politiques de tous les
partis
que va-t-on faire face à marine le pen
il faut se positionner c'est finalement
elle qui est en train de mener la danse
d'une certaine façon en ne faisant rien
puisque les thèmes qu'elle défend des et
il ya des années sont maintenant sur le
devant de la scène
donc c'est dire ça tout le problème les
français aujourd'hui se disent eh bien
après tout peut-être qu'elle avait
raison peut-être que ces idées là
maintenant sont devenus des idées
communes ou avant vous étiez taxé de
raciste vous étaient taxés justement
d'extrémistes c'est devenu d idée
partagée par de plus en plus de français
alors plus en plus
bémol on parle d'un tiers d'un quart de
france est loin d'une majorité mais dans
l'isoloir il se pourrait que face au
rejet de la politique d' emmanuel macron
à ses stratégies politiciennes aussi qui
veulent affaiblir et la droite
traditionnelle et qui a siphonné
certaines voix de gauche et bien les
électeurs de droite plus classique se
tourner vers marine le pen
faute de candidats puisque aujourd'hui
on attend à part xavier bertrand de
savoir qui à droite sera candidat
également pour défendre les couleurs des
républicains aujourd'hui le parti n'a
pas de candidat et ne sais pas
d'ailleurs comment en désignaient il est
l'agent sans doute une partie du
problème à droite et puis marine le pen
n'a pas à faire campagne elle n'a qu'à
attendre finalement avec ses idées qui
infuse et emmanuel macron qui attend lui
également ce match retour qui pourrait
cette fois ci être tout à fait en
défaveur des monnaies le maquereau merci
avec six poulains d'avoir été avec nous
en direct sur rt france presse